une assemblée générale ce matin dans les
locaux administratifs de l'ex conseil
général au centre ville à fort de france
ces employés se plaignent de leurs
conditions sanitaires dans ce bâtiment
pas de toilettes à certains étages et
surtout l'air semble vicié
nous nous sommes resté qu'une heure et
nous avons bien senti cette couche de
poussière sur notre peau pour les
employés de la ctn ce bâtiment est
vétuste c'est un problème d'hygiène au
niveau du ca tmc plus haut bâtiment
c'est dur c'est d'y au bâtiment qui est
vétuste qui n'a jamais fait l'objet de
nettoyage côté nettoyage la poussière
invisible presque partout vous regardez
les couches sociales a accumulé depuis
des années depuis déjà c'est pas nettoyé
c'est pas détruire s'est pas entretenu
c'est pas nettoyé depuis des années
alors vous rendez compte que nous
restions ça on a un public qui qui qui
qui défilent toute la journée on respire
ça on comprend pourquoi il ya des
petites ces petites bêtes nous y
voilà
ce personnel nous avoue voir marché de
temps à autre sur leur corps des puces
sans savoir d'où elles viennent
la fij aussi on a des maisons sera
cassée combettes les jolis les uns les
usagers nous disent mais vous avez des
moustiques chez vous se sont pas des
moustiques ce sont des bêtes mais qu'est
ce que c'est comme bête on ne sait pas
ce sont des essais ce petit pour ans
suppose que c'est peut-être dans la
ventilation parce qu'il ya des oiseaux
qui nichent sur le toit qui nous emmène
des petits des poux comme on l'appelle
des poux d'oiseaux
l'élément déclencheur c'est qu'il ya une
quinzaine de jours que les avions
commencé à avoir des démangeaisons dans
ce bâtiment il aura se sont attachés
qu'ils avaient des petites bestioles qui
étaient dans le bâtiment un dernière
visite les toilettes à certains étages
elles sont inutilisables
environ 400 personnes travaillent dans
ce bâtiment qui a 28 ans et presque
jamais rénover certaines nous avons
avoir des problèmes respiratoires
certains employés de la ctm semble
vouloir se mobiliser jusqu'à ce qu'une
solution soit trouvée
nous avons joint les élus du conseil
exécutif en charge du personnel
ils sont à paris ils seront reçus demain
à l'elysée par emmanuel macron